i don't think we've seen this play out
uh to the full extent yet i think over
the next 72 hours we're going to see a
fun fundamentally different picture for
the ukrainian air force
and i'd expect to see more high-level
engagement by the russian air force over
the next 72 hours so we'll have to watch
the states the question is where has the
the russian air force been so far i mean
initially we saw the initial strikes you
know the traditional way you'd wage your
war is initially through uh offensive
counter-air campaign so first day of the
war we saw cruise missile attacks into
things like um runways uh subservient
society airborne early warning sites
suppressing the enemy air defenses what
would usually expected to see behind
that
is uh an offensive counter counterwear
missions a series of airplanes coming in
to target aircraft bit on the ground
supported by fighters in the air to
ideally you know to take out the
remaining ukrainian aircraft while
they're on the ground but if they do get
airborne
take them out in the air and yet we
haven't seen that we've seen
you know 300 combat aircraft of the
russian air force parked within range of
the ukraine of ukraine sorry but uh
largely inactive and and what this has
allowed is actually the ukrainian air
force to somewhat free reign
um at lower levels in sort of
traditional defensive counter air
measures where they've been able to
attack at low level beyond the the range
and detection uh capabilities of russian
surfs-to-air missiles they've been able
to attack convoys and and troops and
helicopters largely with a large degree
of success and these are some of the
interesting wins you've seen for the
ukrainian air force
the big thing is though what is to come
you have to wonder whether the russian
air force will emerge over time and and
that's the real question as to why they
haven't emerged so far i mean there's
speculation around the actual capability
of the russian air force versus the
perceived capability of what they have
um there's there's speculation around a
lack of sophisticated precision guided
munitions and targeting pods which
allows a certain degree of standoff and
to preserve range without those they
have to get up close and personal which
drags them into within range of of
things like stinger missiles that uh you
ukrainian soldiers can operate on the
ground if we do put a no-fly zone above
that what that is inevitably going to
lead to is direct conflict between nato
pilots and russian pilots
and that is extremely problematic in
terms of the escalatory nature of what
this uh what this potentially could be
so it's a very difficult uh situation
for the west right now i think you look
instinctively we want to protect we want
to put the no-fly zone over the top but
i think uh right now it's a very
difficult proposition for for nato and
it's not one i would anticipate um
happening anytime soon sadly um it's
just not something i think we're capable
of doing right now politically
[Music]